welcome back new rockstars I'm Jessica
Clemens and Paramount Pictures released
a new Transformers rise of the Beast
trailer and not only does this trailer
give us a sneak squeak at Michelle yo
and Pete Davidson's sweet sultry voice
it also introduces Unicron a massive
super powered World eating aka the chaos
bringer monster that literally consumes
other worlds we thought the antagonist
would literally be anyone else but it's
Unicron that's huge news this trailer
also gives us a longer Glimpse at the
fight of all fights in the movie and
freaking RC riding on the back of Ryan
Ox truly I cannot wait for this fight
this war this chaos and there's no other
man I'd love to bring in this chaos with
than the new Rockstar's resident chaos
bringer himself Tommy Beck told oh okay
no one man did say Unicron was gonna be
in this movie One brave soul stepped
forward in our first trailer breakdown
I said this was all gonna be a Trilogy
about Unicron I didn't think he was
going to come in this early I didn't
think he was going to come so hard all
right let's just get into it we got a
glimpse of the scene in the earlier
teaser trailer Optimus primal lands in
the forest facing Optimus Prime and we
assume this is Peru but with more detail
from this trailer it could also be a
different time in Peru or somewhere on
Earth where the maximals have been
hiding or just living and later we see
them transported to Earth in 1994 with
the help of the transworb Keith this is
just a theory based mainly off this
scene right here but we see Optimus
primal and literally King Kong ain't got
on this goddamn gorilla in the
distance you see a huge burden that's
most likely Michelle Yo's character air
razor we start to see the maximals all
together wandering in the forest we see
air razor and Optimus primal soaring
above the trees below we see rhinox and
my baby boy cheetor well I love it I
love it I'll get into it they're clearly
searching or scanning for something as
cheetor prowls in the bushes and air
razor calls in the distant sky and I'm
sorry but I just love her little
steampunk look air razor and cheetor
looks so fun with the real feathers and
fur overlapping the trailer though we
hear Optimus primal voiced by Ron
Perlman say
I said centuries Our Kind has stayed
hiding on Earth the darkness has found
us again God I can't get over that as
soon as they say Darkness the sky turns
black above New York and we see beyond
the Statue of Liberty the Twin Towers
because this movie takes place in 94.
where were you in 94 94 I was at the
little Hammer Olympics downhill skiing
there you go I might have not been born
I love this scene and when Primal says
Prime we're seeing Optimus Prime
transform from the classic big rig
around at the bus depot his foot
literally just like Stomps on the ground
and I yelled step on me Primal finishes
saying this is about the fate of all
living things then we get a glimpse of
the transwarf key with a pair of human
hands so you know we're going to be
causing unknown disasters again and this
is what could have brought the maximals
or alerted Unicron the transworth keys
are famous for helping them travel long
distances in the show then he says
Unicron is coming then we see him next
to the Sun and another planet and look
at this size sometimes Size Doesn't
Matter but here it does and boy this is
a big bad this is the bad bad this is
like a Galactus and Thanos met Unicron
is the overarching villain in the
Transformers but like the Numero Uno bad
bad guy he's not Megatron he's horrible
and they teased him in the bavers like a
piece of Earth but now we're seeing him
as a full-fledged out of Earth
planet-sized Destroyer there genuinely
is like no way I can see him being
stopped because he literally can't be
stopped but the Transformers I'm sure
will find a way I assume he'll be the
major villain overarching the next few
movies because this is his time to use
him as much as possible he is incredible
he'll be voiced by Coleman Domingo and
he is an exceptional voice actor an
exceptional actor on Euphoria Zola
Candyman he's just incredible and
Jessica I just want to say when it comes
to Unicron it's not the size of the
planet it's the suction and the
destruction whoa
we also get a glimpse at Elena played by
Dominic
fact researcher at a museum and what I'm
about to say may come off as a spoiler
so please close your eyes if you don't
want any plot spoilers recently a new
book for children dropped on
Transformers rise of the beast called
Mission at the museum that explores a
researcher at the Ellis Island national
museum of immigration running tests on
an ancient Falcon statue when it
crumbles revealing an ancient artifact
hidden inside another book released
called the search is on covers the
maximals and Autobots traveling to Peru
to find the artifact a race to find it
before Scourge so if this is true the
scene of the hands with the yellow
artifact could potentially be Elena's
and the Crash we see later at the Museum
could be from her already having it okay
Jessica we are back back in 1994 baby
DMX Rough Riders Anthem which came out
in 1998 but I'm not going to complain
plays as we cross the Brooklyn Bridge
this footage is from previous spots but
with some cool Transformers sound
effects added I didn't get that little
Transformer decal in the dashboard of a
mirage oh we finally get to hear Pete
Davidson as Mirage and wouldn't you
believe it he's a chill cool Transformer
who's a little surprised that Anthony
Ramos's character Noah is trying to
fight him with what looks like an
exhaust pipe Prime rolls in but we are a
long way from the human loving Optimus
Prime we saw in the Michael Bay movies
here we see Prime Furious the Mirage
brought a human to the Transformers
garage he puts Noah off the ground with
little regard for his safety this is
consistent with Optimus Prime's Origins
he had to grow to love humans and
clearly in 1994 he had not yet but wait
till Alberto toomba shows him what he
can do on the ski slopes in the Winter
Olympics
a lot of people ask me how I'm able to
stay focused
researching all these vids and honestly
it's this
I can feel the energy surging one shot
Energy Chews are a healthy and
convenient energy boosting supplement
candy for gamers athletes YouTube hosts
everybody really even hunks like me big
Energy Chews and Focus Shoes the focus
shoes are my go-to but it just depends
on what you need each energy shoe has 75
milligrams of pure caffeine plus 600
milligrams of additional nootropics to
give you a serious energy boost that
works immediately as you chew Look at me
now I just chewed I'm practically
jumping out of here Focus Shoes now
available in limited edition new
Rockstar steam packaging really helped
me concentrate and give me a natural
boost of energy with B C D and E
vitamins if there was an F vitamin
they'd have it too plus zinc to help
with immune system support and the amino
acid tyrosine both energy shoes and
focused shoes are plant-based naturally
sweetened and designed to give you the
energy and focus you need without a
bunch of fillers and chemicals get
started with one shot energy today by
going to oneshotenergy.com new rockstars
for 10 off your order
one shot okay also in this scene catch
Bumblebee and
Raj not really helping Noah as Optimus
Prime this guy picks him up and he's got
it we saw peace
first teaser trailer but we didn't see
battle trap unleash on this modified r33
Nissan Skyline sniper one of the
terracons also I don't know cars I had
to look this up we see her transform
over Mirage a little bit later into the
trailer then we get Optimus Prime
staying this is not our war and as a
reminder this takes place in 94 before
Optimus Prime cared about humans like
Tommy said so he probably only cares if
he's directly affected by the terracons
and Predacons probably not caring about
the maximals at all then we see Scourge
battle trap and what I think is
nightbird emerged from the Hudson and
this shot is so I love it I call it a
reverse Sully when things fly out of the
Hudson when air razor AKA Michelle yo
says we must trust each other to protect
the home we all share maybe that's the
wake-up call he needs to realize yeah
we're all in this together regardless
two doors literally bouncing on Mirage
and this could be tied to the scene
earlier where the maximals are wandering
through the forest and cue The Avengers
ass team up I love this we get Optimus
primal cheat or will Jack and look at
his little tiny glasses later you can
see his Finn on his ears but right now
not really an RC and ain't nothing
getting in their way that is until we
just see how massive Unicron actually is
that's a massive Unicron
give me some of that you're gonna cry
and in the more underwhelming part for
me as we know humans have to play some
part in this movie I say underwhelming
because personally when I watch Like
King Kong or Godzilla or Transformers
the last thing I care about are the
humans but this movie already feels like
the ratio is in favor of the cybertrons
versus the humans very very very much so
and guess what take out your dinklages
because we finally hear Peter Dinklage a
Scourge now traditionally Scourge works
for Galvatron he was built by Unicron
from the remains of a dead Decepticon
named shrapnel and I'm sorry if your
name is shrapnel you are going to die
and be added to another Transformer that
is your destiny he's a hunter tracker I
can identify with that he's an alpha
like me he typically leads a group
called The sweeps and it appears that
will be the case in this film we get a
nice moment of Noah embracing his mother
and little brother perhaps saying
goodbye for the last time Mom bro I
gotta go save the world I'm probably not
gonna make it because I'm fighting
alongside and against giant robots
bumblebee gets stabbed there's this blue
light shooting out of him Scourge puts
the emblems of the Autobots he kills on
the grill of his truck and I swear to
God there's a bumblebee on it at the end
of this movie I'm gonna freaking lose it
the museum we see in this movie is not a
real Museum it was created for the film
which makes it a lot easier to destroy
notice the blue energy that's emanating
from Scourge we think that this museum
is the New York museum of archeology
where Atlanta works we see the small
circular well thing that was in the
first trailer if you remember that was
followed by that sweet Peruvian parade
it's possible this is where the
transwarp key is we get a great shot of
a lush Green Valley with what appears to
be some sort of large transforming
machine perhaps sent from Unicron
changing the landscape with the same
blue energy that Scourge had at the
Museum what is this blue energy what
does it mean Autobots assemble as we
said once again we get another great
look at cheat tour RC wheeljacking his
crazy ass glasses Optimus Prime Optimus
Prime oh grandson grandfather hanging
out with their friend rhinox they're all
together and then finally at 151 he said
the thing what's the thing let them come
ugh damn this seems like a flashback to
Unicron devouring a planet with that
familiar blue energy again in that next
shot I believe we're getting a look at
night bird lighting up the museum this
poor Museum I know it's fictional but
come on it looks like in this next shot
Elena is hanging off of Unicron but
we're definitely not on Earth unless
Earth is in really rough shape yeah it's
on fire the floor is lava we got a nice
shot of Noah on rapper Toby and wigwei
in his film debut just kind of smiling
in a car I don't know why it made the
trailer they're like we don't show the
humans more so right now we've got the
autobots and the maximals then the
terracons and some Predacons and we see
Optimus Prime Optimus primal and rhinox
charging far left of the screen you can
see Bumblebee and who I assume is Alana
riding RC as her motorcycle then we see
Optimus primal smashing a scorpinox this
scene I wanted to punch a hole through
my computer how excited I was there
looks to be so many of these scorpions
that it's insane we saw them ages ago
literally in the first movie go back and
watch the very first movie they show up
in the desert next to him is I think
Noah in the exo suit then swinging like
a goddamn gorilla he is by biting the
head off another score for Knox I eat
this up on the ground we've got
Cheeto on the attack and if I don't get
a goddamn tattoo of cheater by the end
of this movie I swear to God can I do it
yeah if you can draw you can draw you're
good at Doodles RC comes in guns blazing
on the back of rhinox flipping in the
air to support wheel Jack like literally
are you kidding me how does this not
look sick as hell yeah it's amazing oh
God I am obsessed with this then we get
the Transformers logo with the oh and
the former switching between the
different emblems emerage possibly
giving Noah the exo suit like in
generation one Series so hopefully we
get more humans in these giant robot
suits and I am volunteering as troopers
absolutely then we close the trailer to
bumblebee sliding through other robots
and on top of them isn't Noah again in
the exo suit and it looks so close to
Mirage I'm wondering if Mirage has the
ability to make the suit out of just
like a single piece of himself if they
have that technology yet mark it down
that's a theory that's a theory that's
it for Tommy and I's breakdown for the
latest Transformer rise of the Beast
trailer let us know in the comments if
you're as excited as I am as we are we
are excited and if you want to support
this ding dong Channel check out the
awesome merch at nerd riot.shop tell
them you want a Transformer inspired
shirt gosh dang it oh my God nerd Riot
dot shot follow me on Instagram and
Twitter Tommy Bechtel if you can follow
my moon and stars Jessica Clemens at
Lulu Clemens on all platforms follow me
rockstars follow me home see where I
live I've got a pool and a basketball
court subscribe to new rockstars for
more breakdowns don't forget to
subscribe to our other channel the Deep
dive as well thanks for watching now get
out autobots assemble Roblox
oh
[Music]